so here here comes a phone call right  now  bow-wow meow now I can answer this on my  watch or I can send a message and reply  or answer on my iPhone if I like I'm  going to answer right on my Apple watch  hi this is Kevin hi Kevin this is Sarah  calling from cloud meow  you don't Finnegan it's ready to be  picked up okay great I'll be right over  as soon as the event is done okay okay  thank you bye  really easy to take those calls wherever  you are and the great thing is that  Apple watch communicates with your  iPhone over Wi-Fi as well as Bluetooth  so when you're home you don't have to be  within Bluetooth range of your phone it  can be anywhere in your house and still  get all your messages and take your  phone calls just like that